la très grande majorité des plantes qui
nous nourrissent ont besoin d'être
polliniser pour fournir de bonnes
récoltes mais les menaces qui pèsent sur
les pollinisateurs comme les abeilles ou
les bourdons sont nombreuses d'ailleurs
plusieurs espèces sont déjà en déclin
voilà pourquoi l'arrivée d'un nouveau
prédateur sur la côte ouest tient les
autorités et les apiculteurs en alerte
[Musique]
les médias
d'être coeur
depuis de mon enfance je suis intéressé
en insectes en général alors et bien sûr
jardiner ça fait partie du monde des
cinq sets
[Musique]
l'apiculture a toujours été un loisir
j'ai travaillé quelques années chez un
agriculteur mais ça reste un parce
qu'on rate bérubé moufid un hall du
belchen et son mari john font partie du
club des apiculteurs de nanaimo sur
l'île de vancouver
ils produisent leur miel mais échangent
aussi des informations quand survient
une maladie ou l'arrivée d'un danger
pour les abeilles
[Musique]
voici la reine à l'origine de ce nid de
frelons géant asiatique qui a été
découvert à nanaimo
c'est la plus grosse guêpe au monde
comme vous pouvez le voir elle fait à
peu près la taille de mon pouce c'est
une grosse bête
piste
le frelon géant asiatique de son vrai
nom le fais pas mandarine ya est
originaire d'asie on le retrouve de
l'inde au japon cet insecte qui vit à
l'état sauvage là bas n'est pas le
bienvenu ici
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas officielle mais nous
croyons que ces frelons sont arrivés via
le transport maritime
l'entomologiste paul van west end up
mène la bataille contre cet insecte pour
le gouvernement de la
colombie-britannique
c'est un important prédateurs car les
abeilles n'ont aucune façon de se
défendre contre ce frelon donc si les
apiculteurs ne protège pas leurs
colonies d'abeilles et pourraient
devenir des proies faciles pour les
frelons scouby djob job to protège or
ces frelons constitue un risque pour les
humains puisque leur nid et dans le sol
si vous dénoncez la colonie ça pourrait
devenir dangereux au japon il y à chaque
année de 30 à 50 personnes qui meurent
des suites de leur big
[Musique]
la détection de cet insecte à nanaimo
souffle un vent de panique chez les
apiculteurs
une course contre la montre pour trouver
le nid et le détruire
je pense que c'était ici oui c'est ça
ici
[Musique]
on s'est rendu sur place et en quelques
heures on a détruit
il y en avait 200 folon et 600 larves et
on a été très ému quand on a vu la reine
pas ce que ça veut dire que on attend on
trouvera en marraine c'est la fin d'une
ihm et aussi comme apiculteur nos
beaucoup de respect pour les rênes de
toute espèce qui affecte
pour ces apiculteurs devenu
exterminateurs d'un jour cette aventure
ne s'est pas fait sans douleur
ah oui
j'ai été piqué quatre fois de suite aux
cuisses là où mes vêtements me coller
aux jambes ce jour là je suis devenu la
deuxième personne avoir été piqué par un
frelon asiatique en amérique du nord
john robinson est le premier à avoir eu
cet honneur
la piqûre est intense mais j'avais plus
l'impression d'avoir été frappé par un
doute par 4 à ce match de rugby stade
même si la douleur est vive je suis
content d'avoir été piqué et d'en
connaître les effets pour pouvoir les
expliquer
plus de deux ans après cette histoire le
frelon géant asiatique n'a pas été revu
sur l'île de vancouver ce qui est une
excellente nouvelle
la norme que l'on s'est fixés c'est que
si aucun unis n'est recensé pendant deux
années d'affilée on considère le secteur
débarrasser du prédateur
mais la bataille n'est pas
officiellement terminée car encore cette
année quelques frelons ont été observés
sur le continent des deux côtés de la
frontière des opérations d'éradication
denis ont eu lieu dans le nord de l'état
de washington et les équipes continuent
de ratisser le territoire pour piéger
des frelons
nous pensons que les frelons ont du mal
à se déplacer vers l'est en colombie
à cause des chaînes de montagne et du
ski n'a plus attrayant pour eux
mais dans le tas doit s'il tonne c'est
un réel problème on craint que ces
frelons migrent vers le sud plus
particulièrement vers des zones
agricoles en oregon boirin californie où
ce serait très problématique
malgré cette crainte selon lui il n'y a
pas lieu de paniquer car tous les
efforts d'éradication sont en place
je crois que les frelons sera soumis à
une forte pression de la part des
humains la tolérance envers cet insecte
sera nulle et tous les nids trouver
seront détruits
pour les apiculteurs amateurs
l'expérience a été enrichissante et
maintenant la vigilance est de mise
c'est très gratifiant d'avoir pu
partager nos connaissances et
conscientiser le public sur l'importance
d'éliminer une espèce envahissante et de
protéger les insectes pollinisateurs
ce soir là c'était un événement
traumatique pour moi et mon mari mais
aussi ça nous a lancés dans une
aventure si vous voulez de d'apprendre
plus en plus et deux de donner à la
communauté ce que nous apprenons pour
que eux ils sont préparés aussi
[Musique]